mes chers collègues la deuxième table
ronde de la matinée met en évidence sous
forme d'interrogation l'angoisse de
nombreux chefs d'entreprise face à la
directive
CSRD la complexité administrative
normative est en effet au cœur de leur
préoccupation et explique que le sujet
soit si important pour la délégation aux
entreprises pour répondre à cette
question interviendront ce matin dans
l'ordre suivant Monsieur Patrick de
Cambourg président du comité de
reporting sur le développement durable
de l'effrag tenant du concept de la
double matérialité retenue par l'Union
européenne monsieur le Président vous
pourrez présenter ce concept et nous
expliquer pourquoi il est important à
vos
yeux ensuite nous entendrons Monsieur
Thierry philippona chef économiste à
Finance Watch organisation non
gouvernementale européenne dont la
vocation est de favoriser une industrie
financière responsable et durable le
dernier rapport publié mardi 31 octobre
par votre organisation finance in hot
house World la dans un monde brûlant
considère qu'en sous-estimant les
répercussions financières du changement
climatique les économistes encourage les
politiques à l'inaction et que les
banques financent encore trop largement
les énergies fossiles comment
appréhendez-vous dans ce contexte les
directives CSRD et enfin en
visioconférence interviendra Monsieur
Emmanuel Faber président de l'issb qui a
publié le 26 juin 2023 ses normes
extrafinancières position de l'issb peu
favorable au concept européen de double
matérialité ne vous a pas empêché de
publier lundi dernier une tribune plutôt
nuancée sur le sujet prenant une
collaboration au niveau mondial peut-on
échapper à une bataille des normes avec
les
États-Unis nous vous remercions tous
trois de votre présence pour un débat
qui peut paraître à la fois très
technique et difficile à appréhender
mais qui est fondamental pour la
compétitivité de nos entreprises je vais
tout d'abord vous céder la parole pour
un propos liminaire que je vous prierai
de bien vouloir limiter à à peu près 8
minutes afin de laisser le maximum de
temps aux échanges qui devront se
terminer à 10h20 au plus tard ensuite
mes collègues vous poseront les
questions des questions à commencer par
les rapporteurs de cette mission
anne-esophie Romani et Marion Canales je
rappelle que cette table ronde est
retransmise en direct et sera disponible
en vidéo à la demande sur le site
internet du Sénat à vous la parole donc
en ensemble par Monsieur le Président de
Cambour merci monsieur le Président et
bonjour à
tous Je je voudrais dire que à l'issue
d'un effort de qui a qui a
démarré en 2020 et même peut-être par
par de multiples aspects antérieurement
mais un effort politique majeur de
l'Union euh la question de la donnée de
la qualité de la donnée en en matière de
sustainability de durabilité est en voie
de
euh est en train de de connaître une
phase majeure de
progrès en fait la situation exanté
était une situation extrêmement
dangereuse qui conduisait à des risques
que l'on qualifie de green washing ou
d'sg washing puisque dans le fond euh il
n'y avait pas de norm il y avait des
initiatives multiples la donnée n'était
pas vérifiée elle n'était pas comparable
donc elle ne répondait pas aux objectifs
de qualité qui sont nécessaires pour
qu'on puisse travailler sérieusement
parce qu'il n'y a pas en fait de
politique publique de stratégie privée
d'allocation de capital sans que la
donnée soit fiable c'était le problème
fondamental
et donc la nouvelle Commission mise en
place en décembre 2019 qui avait été
sensibilisé par de multiples acteurs je
fais à mon modeste niveau référence à un
rapport que j'avais fait pour le
ministre de l'Économie des Finances en
2019 sur ces sujets-là mais je n'étais
pas le seul loin de là à souligner les
risques euh à à rester comme nous étions
à l'époque donc la nouvelle Commission
par la voix de son vice-président
exécutif Dombrovskis dès janvier 20 a
dit il faut que nous résolvions ce
problème de la qualité de la donnée donc
en fait je je fais très court parce que
il y a eu de multiples épisodes et de
multiples débats politiques de multiples
efforts techniques au niveau de l'erague
pour arriver
à une étape majeure qui est celle de
l'adoption de la CSRD l'année dernière
en donc publié en décembre
2022 qui a fait l'objet du d'une
transposition en France le 7 décembre
donc très
récemment et et le deuxième volet de ce
dispositif qui avait été annoncé dès
janvier 2020 c'est-à-dire le
dispositif norme parce que c'est bien
d'avoir des grands principes mais la
pratique de de
l'information est une pratique qui
requiert des normes détaillées
d'établissement comme on le voit dans
l'information financière l'objectif
n'est autre que de créer une deuxème un
deuxème pilier à l'information normée
des entreprises le pilier de durabilité
en connectivité en connexion avec le
pilier financier qui est relativement
stabilisé et bien connu qui a ses
qualités et ses défaut mais dont on sait
les qualités c'est que il est stabilisé
et qu'il parle des choses qui ont une
nature monétaire son défaut c'est qu'il
se limite à un certain nombre par ses
principes fondateurs un certain nombre
de points qui ne sont pas des points de
vision d'avenir ou qui s'arrêtent aux
limites de l'entreprise et de ses
filiales donc voilà le point fondamental
était éta était cela et
avec donc la publication des standards
européens les fameuses
ESRS European suain reporting standards
euh le 31 juillet
dernier qui a fait l'objet d'un examen
par le Parlement européen et par le
Conseil les
colégislateurs jusqu'à fin octobre qui
n'a pas conduit à rejeter ce texte dans
le cadre de la délégation qui avait été
donnée à la Commission et bien ces
standards sont aujourd'hui dans le
système juridique européen applicable au
aux 27 pays de
l'Union donc je nous considérons enfin
je je je considère et je pense que le le
le conseil que j'ai l'honneur de
présider où d'ailleurs Thierry
philippona siège est effectivement
heureux de ce dénouement qui était
attendu on pourrait même à certains
égards dire que nous aurions dû
commencer avant parce que parfois euh on
met la charue avant les bœfs en Europe
euh et et pas seulement en Europe
peut-être mais je vous laisse juge
euh on on demande des on on crée des
obligations de comportement on crée des
obligations de reporting alors que la
donnée n'existe pas donc il était
absolument essentiel de résoudre cette
question de la donnée de base une donnée
qui doit avoir des caractéristiques
d'objectivité et qui ne qui n'emporte
pas d'ailleurs des comportements mais
qui simplement les expliquent alors donc
je je je voulais dire cela je ne rentre
pas dans le détail du dispositif
normatif qui a été mis en place et je
seraai heureux de
d'éclairer la la délégation si elle le
souhaite mais je voudrais insister sur
sur deux points qui m'pparaissent
importants le premier c'est cette
fameuse histoire de la double
matérialité je pense que c'est un débat
je le dis d'emblé qui est tout tout à
fait exagéré et qui est caricaturé dans
une large mesure alors j'utilise des
mots un peu un peu
forts de quoi s'agit-il l'entreprise a
des relations c'est ce qu'on appelle la
relation intérieure extérieure
c'està-dire qu'elle a un un impact sur
son environnement au sens environnement
du terme et sur son environnement social
c'est évident donc on appelle ça le
reporting d'impact très bien par
ailleurs évidemment l'entreprise doit
euh euh faire attention à ses risques
mais aussi prendre en compte ses
opportunités sous l'angle de sa
performance
financière et dans le fond euh on a
tendance à opposer les deux notions donc
ce que l'on appelle l'intérieur vers
l'extérieur l'impact et l'extérieur vers
l'intérieur c'est-à-dire les risques et
opportunités
pour moi ce sont deux réalités qui sont
très largement
imbriquées car d'ailleurs les
standards que
l'issb a produit sont des standards qui
le démontrent aujourd'hui euh nous
sommes largement euh
en la la norme climat de l'issb à de
nombreux impacts euh prend en compte de
nombreux impacts donc il n'y a pas
d'opposition parce que quels sont les
impacts d'une entreprise sur son
environnement ou sur les personnes qui
n'auraient pas de conséquences
financières dès l'instant qu'il s'agit
d'impact significatif donc ça c'est je
puisque vous avez posé la question
monsieur le Président de la double
matérialité j'exprime l'idée que les
deux sont très
interconnectés et qu'il
faut prendre en compte les deux
dimensions deuxième point dans la limite
du temps qui qui m'a été imparti je
voulais dire aussi que l'Europe s'est
efforcé de afin d'éviter de des rapports
multiples
d'intégrer les avancées qui étaient en
cours à l'issb et qui ont été traduites
par les standards publiés en
juin donc nous avons le sentiment que
les entreprises européennes qui
prépareront des rapports en application
des ESRS incorporeront la quasittalité
des informations qui sont requise au
plan qui serait requise au plan
international donc la perspective de
l'issb est intégrée dans la perspective
européenne de même il existe
une une une initiative qui s'appelle la
Global reporting initiative qui a une
antériorité assez grande de plus de 20
ans en matière de reporting d'impact et
nous avons là aussi travaillé la main
dans la main avec eux pour faire en
sorte que l'essentiel de ce qu'il défend
et qui était d'ailleurs demandé par la
CSRD soit intégré pour éviter là encore
un double rapport donc oui c'est une
étape importante oui ça n'est pas ça ne
se règle pas en un en un
tournem mais si on veut être sérieux en
matière d' d'information de durabilité
il faut franchir cette première étape et
l'organisation que que j'anime se tourne
aujourd'hui partiellement parce qu'il y
a d'autres tâches mais sur le support à
la mise en œuvre nous avons ouvert
une une plateforme de questions-réponses
et nous envoyons et nous préparons aussi
des guides d'application multiples donc
nous sommes très engagés dans la
relation avec les entreprises voilà
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Monsieur Philippe
Président Mesdames les rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs très heureux
d'être avec vous ce matin pour aborder
ces vous m'avez proposé de regarder à
nous tous d'ailleurs la question des des
enjeux de la directive CSRD et puis
monsieur le Président vous avez fait
allusion à un rapport que effectivement
F watch Finance Watch a publié récemment
je concluraai sur ce sujet-là peut-être
pour déjà regarder et et il y a un lien
naturel en fait entre entre ces deux ces
deux questions donc la la question est
plus que pertinente donc déjà sur les
enjeux de la crcrd je pense qu'il est
très important de le de mettre cette
CSRD en perspective parce qu'il y a
souvent des malentendus comme il est
normal sur un sujet technique donc quels
sont quels sont les enjeux d'abord on
s'inscrit dans la dynamique de
réglementation de la finance durable au
niveau européen
voilà ça c'est quelque chose qui est
très très importante à faire à voir et
c'est la dynamique générale de l'agenda
finan durable de l'Union européenne
repose sur formation en gros on va
essayer de donner une meilleure
information en quantité et en qualité à
tous les acteurs afin qu'ils aient les
repères l'information pour faire un
travail qui on l'espère j'ai bien dit on
l'espère si on a le temps on en parlera
pourrait aboutir vers le fait que les
flux financiers vont
vers la transformation de nos économies
vers la durabilité c'est ça la logique
et nous avons déjà un certain nombre de
réglementation en œuvre en place dans
l'Union européenne qui crée des
obligations de reporting on prend
toujours ce mot anglais je pas vra troué
en
français pour les institutions
financières et rapportage allez allons-y
pour le
rapportage et donc les les institions
financières ont des obligations sfdr
taxonomie et autres et évidemment si les
financiers ont des obligation de je vais
garder le mot reporting il faut bien
qu'ils aient eux-mêm l'information don
ils ont besoin et la CR CRD infin
elle va consister à dire bah mettons un
peu de rigueur dans tout ça et regardons
ce que les entreprises doivent dire au
financiers afin que les financiers
eux-mêmes fassent un leur travail
d'allocation du capital dans la
direction de la durabilité et puis
eux-mêmes fassent leur reporting c'est
très important de voir ça parce que
c'est une pièce d'un grand puzzle ça
c'est la première chose après ça il y a
deux façons d'aborder la question de la
crcrd la première c'est de voir la crcrd
comme une carte routière c'est une carte
routière
ce n'est pas l'obligation d'aller
quelque part la CSRD n'est pas
coercitive la seule obligation qu'elle
crée c'est de dire de rapporter elle dit
pas vous êtes obligé de faire elle dit
dites-moi ce que vous faites non c'est
non c'est très important parce que
d'autres réglementations par exemple il
y en a une qui est actuellement en
discussion au niveau de de l'Union
européenne qui n'est pas encore bouclée
dite dans le magnifique
jargon à la fois anglais et bruxellois
de CSDD donc la la directive sur le le
le devoir de vigilance dans la chaîne de
valeur et cetera là elle crée ou elle
créera on verra des obligations la CSRD
c'est dites-moi ce que vous faites c'est
c'est quelque chose de très très
important à faire donc de la même façon
qu'une carte routière vous emmène pas là
où vous voulez aller parce qu'il faut
encore qu'il a un véhicule et et un
conducteur qui veul y aller là on est
dans la carte routière c'est quelque
chose de très
important la deuxième chose c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure c'est qu'il y a
des obligations de reporting dans l'
européenne et il faut absolument les
nourrir mon message principal ici il est
triple la première chose c'est que
l'information prévue par la CSRD est une
condition nécessaire mais non suffisante
de la transition de nos économies vers
la
durabilité l'information même de qualité
parfaite et en quantité parfaitement
calibré c'est-à-dire ni trop ni trop peu
vous aurez compris qu'il y a une forme
d'ironie dans ce que je dis parce que
aucun système n'est parfait et personne
ne prétend que ce qui est en train
d'être mis sur la table est parfait
parce que voilà on est dans monde réel
et c'est bien complexe mais imaginons
l'espace d'un qu'on crée un système
parfait formidable d'accord est-ce que
ça va suffire pour que les flux
financiers
aillent instantanément vers la
durabilité non pourquoi pourquoi y
revenir parce que en matière de
durabilité infidé il faudra des
politiques publiques qui prennent les
décisions qui sont difficiles on sait
tous qu'elles sont difficiles je suis
pas pour autant en train de dire que
l'information n'est pas utile elle est
indispensable elle est indispensable
comme la comptabilité é indispensable
pour
juger de la rentabilité ou de la non
rentabilité d'une entreprise mais
évidemment le meilleur système comptable
ne crée pas l'obligation ni
l'automatisme pour que toutes les
entreprises deviennent rentables c'est
vraiment très très important à voir
parce que sur ce sujet il y a souvent
des des confusions la deuxième chose qui
est vraiment importante c'est que la
durabilité est une condition du
développement économique de l'activité
économique et de la prospérité je dois
avouer là je parle vraiment à titre
personn que je certains débats me
laissent un peu panti quand j'entends
opposer durabilité et compétitivité
quand on lit les rapports du GC pas moi
qui parle sont les scientifiques du
GC bon on espère que tout ce qu'il
prédis ne va pas se produire mais si ça
se produit pour la compétitivité des
entreprises et la prospérité du monde je
vais utiliser un ophémisme ça va pas
être
extraordinaire la troisème chose je vais
pas revenir sur la définition de la
double matérialité parce que que Patrick
de Cambourg nous l'a expliqué il y a il
y a quelques minutes mais la double
matérialité elle est dans la loi
européenne et j'ai presque envie de dire
on l'aime ou on l'aime pas c'est la loi
donc nous autres Européens bah on va
l'appliquer après ça au-delà de ce
constat il faut que je fasse vite j'en
ai conscience j'ai entendu certaines
voix sélevé pour dire que l' matérialité
d'impact de la double matérité parce que
double matérité c'est matérité d'impact
matérité financière était à la fois et
simpliste j'aimerais partager avec vous
quelques réflexions sur ce
sujet la première réflexion c'est que
tout le monde est d'accord pour dire que
la matérialité financière dans ces deux
dimensions de risque et d'opportunité
est essentielle et cela est reconnu par
la loi européenne et par les standards
de reporting de durabilité européen ESRS
par définition qui dit double
matérialité dit matérialité financière
c'est c'est c'est c'est
intrinsèque la deuxième chose c'est
qu'il existe aujourd'hui un niveau de
convergence très élevé sur le segment
matérialité financière pour les
questions climatique entre les normes
qui ont été élaborées à la base par les
frag et ensuite adopté par l'Union
européenne et par celle de l'issb le
niveau de convergence est très élevé on
ne peut que s'en féliciter c'est une
excellente chose et évidemment c'est pas
arrivé par hasard c'est arrivé du fait
de la détermination et du travail
acharné des deux institutions que sont
l'isssb frag qui concrètement monsieur
Faber nous en parlera seûement tout à
l'heure ont travaillé ensemble se sont
dit évidemment il faut qu'il y ait une
convergence parce que sinon sinon
d'abord ça va être trop compliqué donc
essayons de simplifier donc ça c'est une
chose dont il faut se féliciter le trème
point c'est que la matérialité d'impact
elle est ni plus ni moins simpliste et
naïve que la matérialité financière la
réalité c'est que ces deux catégories de
matérialité sont comparables dans la
façon dont elles impactent le monde
aujourd'hui et malheureusement dans
l'état actuel des choses les
informations qui sont publiées ou qui
seront publiées au titre de l'une ou
l'autre matérialité ne sont pas
suffisantes par elle-même et c'est très
important le par elle-même pour avoir un
impact sur le monde je vais vous donner
un exemple très très concret de ce que
je dis et là je reste sur la matalité
Financière le sujet est celui des actifs
d'énergie fossile d échoué le président
de la République Emmanuel Macron l'a
très très bien dit dans son dans son
discours à la COP 28 quand il a dit que
ses réserves perdront à terme toutes
leur valeur beaucoup d'analystes l'ont
dit notre président de la République l'a
dit à terme les réserve d'énergie
fossile vont perdre leur valeur c'est
quand même quelque chose de très
important donc si on raisonne en
reporting de durabilité matériité
financière
a ça va perdre sa valeur c'est pas
neutre au niveau financier évidemment on
on est en train de parler quand même de
d'ordre de grandeur de
l'ordre il y a différentes estimations
mais plus de 1000 milliards de dollars
au niveau mondial donc on n pas en train
de parler de quelque chose de de
négligeable ce fait technique est
reconnu par les
spécialistes mais aujourd'hui la
comptabilité financière qui valorise les
réserve de pétrole de gaz et de charbon
pour appeler un chat chat à leur valeur
de marché
valorise à la hausse C ces réserves donc
si vous êtes investisseur en pétrole en
gaz ou en charbon depuis quelques années
et bien vous avez été très prospère vous
êtes enrichi est-ce que ça veut dire que
quelqu'un a tort non on est juste sur
deux systèmes qui même en matérialité
financière ne se réconcilie pas
aujourd'hui et on voit tous
immédiatement que la question c'est une
question d'horizont temps parce que la
comptabilité financière regarde la
valeur aujourd'hui et puis fonctionne
sur une base annuelle et évidemment et
c'est c'est ce que disait très bien le
président Macron et tous les
spécialistes qui ont travaillé sur le
sujet depuis une quinzaine
d'années la question des actifs échoués
autrement dit de la perte de valeur de
des des actifs d'énergie fossile qui
seront pris en compte dans la dimension
matérialité financière du reporting de
durabilité et bien est-ce que c'est dans
10 ans dans 20 ans dans 30 ans moi je
suis pas plus malin que les autres je
sais pas à terme c'est inévitable c'est
signé voilà donc là on on voit bien ce
qui veut dire que la Matéri financière
elle-même en reporting de
durabilité n'a pas plus d'impact sur les
marchés financiers aujourd'hui que la
matérialité d'impact peut avoir pour
miraculeusement entre guillemets changer
le monde d'un d'un claement de doigt
très très brièvement car je suis trop
long ça va je
tiens le reporting de durabilité il est
indispensable prier point deuxème
question il n'y a aucune raison de poser
la double materalité de la CSRD et la
materalité Financière vous avez compris
mais mon point
là-dessus le trisème point c'est qu'il
serait naïf de croire que la seule
information sera suffisante pour la
dimension financière nous devons
réconcilier les horizons temps pas
simple mais la problématique elle est là
pour la dimension matérialité d'impact
nous avons besoin des politiques
publiques adéquates pas simple non plus
mais au moins il faut l'avoir en
tête la plus grande erreur de mon point
de vue serait depposer l'économie et la
durabilité parce que c'est juste le même
sujet c'est juste le même sujet on aime
tous le long terme une entreprise à long
terme c'est une entreprise par
définition ça se construit à long terme
et enfin et je serais très bref même si
vous m'avez lancé là-dessus monsieur le
Président effectivement nous avons chez
sorti un rapport il y a il y a un mois
et demi disant que si on
sous-estimer le coût économique du
changement climatique alors les
responsables politique n'avait pas
l'information nécessaire pour prendre
les bonnes décisions parce que un
responsable politique au bout du compte
il pèse le coût de l'inaction il pèse le
coûpt de l'action et si on lui dit le
coût de l'inaction bah il est pas si
élevé que ça par contre le coût de
l'action est élevé et il est élevé le
coût de l'action ben il va dire bah
désolé moi j'arbitre c'est normal c'est
c'est l'essence même de de la décision
politique donc on a poussé dans ce
sens-l mais évidemment pour relier à
notre sujet du jour je Seris heureux de
venir parler de ce rapport longuement
dans commission une autre fois
évidemment il y a une dimension
information et la bonne information qui
peut nourrir ces évaluations et ses
estimations est absolument essentielle
donc c'est là que que que se ferait le
pont et je serai heureux d'approfondir
si vous le souhaitez merci Monsieur
Philippe ha monsieur Faber monsieur le
Président nous sommes à votre
écoute très très
bien
notre semaine de conseil public ici pour
pouvoir euh participer à vos vos
réflexions qui sont je crois vraiment
importantes vous allez entendre l'écho
de quelqu'un
qui est français européen convaincu
engagé sur les questions de transition
depuis 30 ans pu que j'ai été nommé
directeur financier d'une entreprise euh
et et et puis aujourd'hui euh comme on
l'a tous entendu euh euh
animant l'international sustainability
standard board dans l'objectif de porter
la création d'une infrastructure de
marché en matière de transparence sur
les questions de durabilité à l'échelle
systémique
et ça pour une raison fondamentale qui a
été rappelé d'ailleurs à la fois par
Thierry philippena et et et Patrick qui
est que cette transition elle repose sur
deux et je vais prendre le risque de
dire deux
seulement très grand piliers le premier
c'est celui de politique publique engagé
rien rien ne remplacera des politiques
publiques engagées et euh
Thierry philippona a souhaité évoquer
l'intérêt de la matérialité
d'impact j'en parle en connaissance de
cause j'ai utilisé les normes de la
Global reporting initiative du depuis 15
ans chez Danon on a fait du reporting
intégré chez Danon dès 2013 plus de 10
ans et on a
publié notre périmètre complet
d'émission de gaz à effet de serre y
compris l'indir direct dans toutes les
chaînes de valeur depuis 2009 donc euh
je je suis intimement persuadé de
l'importance de la matérialité d'impact
j'ai cofondé je pense une des toutes
premières chaires de
comptabilité
multicapitaux en France avec L'Oréal euh
voilà donc c'est des sujets sur lequel
j'ai un peu d'expérience et une assez
grande profondeur de de d'engagement et
et pour moi il s'agit nullement de
remettre la question de la matérialité
d'impact et du reporting à toutes les
parties prenantes en question mais
simplement en perspective et j'y
reviendrai sur de mon point de vue les
les enjeux de la de la CSRD de son
application en France en particuliier
donc je disais premier pilier absolument
essentiel les politiques publiques rien
ne les remplacera euh elles ne sont
aujourd'hui pas à la hauteur de ce que
nous dit la science vous le savez après
chacun et comme l'a dit Thierry Philippe
PONARD euh
chaque chaque juridiction a ses
consensus ses consensus politiques ses
marches de manœuvre et graduellement il
faut espérer qu'on va arriver à se
mettre en marche collectivement vers
tout ça le deuxième pili est absolument
nécessaire c'est des marchés des
capitaux bien informés et de ce point de
vuel la CSRD est un très grand pas en
avant et à l'échelle internationale on
essaie de faire notre travail sur le sur
le même sujet pourquoi parce par que il
faut être très très clair et je pense
qu'il y a pas d'ambiguité dans cette
salle le le ce ne sont pas les
gouvernements qui vont financer cette
transition ce sont les marchés
financiers imaginez simplement que il a
fallu trois copes pour rassembler 100
milliards d'euros à l'échelle de la
planète pour un fond qu'on a appelé de
loss and damages de perte dommag pour
les pays les plus atteints dans
le dans les pays du Sud par les pays
développés 100 milliards d'euros euh
il est les ordres de grandeur dont on
parle à l'échelle de la planète c'est
entre 2 et 4 trilliards d'euros annuel
qu'il faut allouer à la
transition la capitalisation boursière
de tous les instruments financiers de
capital dans le monde et de dett côté
les émissions obligataires c'est
400000 milliards c'est 400 trilliards
donc ça veut dire que si les marchés
financés dotés de politiqu publi qui
créent des risques de transition et doté
d'information qui leur permettent de les
intégrer dans leur calcul de risque et
d'opportunités dans le business model
des
entreprises si ces marchés financiers
sont dotés de ce système d'information
il suffira de ne faire bouger que 1 % de
la capitalisation mondiale tous les ans
pour financer les 4000 milliards dont
tout le monde parle pour dire que c'est
ça ce qu'il faut globalement comme ordre
de grand annuel donc la discion
discussion qu'on a c'est une discussion
vraiment importante de ce point de
vue-là et c'est la raison pour laquelle
en ce qui me concerne j'ai choisi d'y
consacrer un peu de montant sur les
quelques les quelques années qui
viennent donc la la CSRD elle comporte
en réalité cette double entrée de
politique publique avec des objectifs de
politique publique d'un côté et de
l'autre côté des objectifs de politique
économique dans dans sa capacité à faire
bouger les allocations de de de capital
je reviens pas sauf si vous avez des
question si vous en avait on le fera
avec Patrick sur ce qui a été partagé
sur le niveau d'alignement de nos normes
en tout cas sur le plan
climatique et et et et et ça n'est pas
seulement pour faire simple comme l'a
dit Thierry philippona je pense que
c'est extrêmement important de
simplifier la vie des entreprises ça
c'est ça c'est clair c'est-à-dire
que l'un des principaux enjeux de la
mise en œuvre de la CSRD ça va être
cette question là on le sait très bien
sur sa faisabilité même politique je
dirais dans la dans la mise en place euh
mais c'est bien la question de où sont
les risques et les opportunités et
aujourd'hui dans le système comptable je
partage complètement l'analyse qui a été
faite par euh mes mes les deux
intervenants précédent euh nous ne
comptons pas tout ce qui compte et pas
dans les bons horizons et donc euh le
projet en matérialité économique de
l'issb et dans sa partie de matérialité
économique pour la CSRD c'est déclair
les informations sur la totalité des
chaînes de valeur et sur l'obligation de
regarder un temps court moyen et long
dans lequel les actifs échoués qu'on
évoquait précédemment apparaîtront
puisque nous demandons comme le fait
d'ailleurs la CSRD
que les
impacts de ces éléments sur les comptes
financiers d'aujourd'hui mais aussi de
demain soit
clarifié donc vous allez voir apparaître
et on a commencé à le voir des
discussions sur les intangibles les
intangibles qui représentent au bilan
des entreprises des grandes entreprises
et les entreprises côé en particulier la
plus grande partie des bilans
aujourd'hui à compter par les survaleurs
d'acquisition à commencer pardon par les
survaleur d'acquisition sur lesquel les
entreprises font des paris à très très
très long terme donc elles savent voir à
très long terme quand elles intègrent
une survaleur dans leur bilan donc c'est
pas l'incapacité des entreprises à à
regarder le long terme c'est leur
incapacité pour l'instant à regarder les
scénarios climat à les intégrer dans un
dispositif stratégique qui les amènerait
à réviser la valeur dans les de sens
peut-être d'ailleurs des des actifs
qu'elles ont
comptabilisé dans leur dans leur
bilan si je viens maintenant sur la la
question de des des enjeux pour moi
c'est vraiment une question d'équilibre
euh il y a un risque le le risque
principal de mon point de vue c'est que
la CS SRD soit euh mise en œuvre par les
entreprises dans un objectif de
conformité
euh parce que quoi qu'on en dise la
conformité ne fait pas bouger les
allocations de capital elle peut-être
importante pour des raisons de de
politique publique c'est-à-dire que si
on décide qu'en Europe c'est important
de reporter sur tel et tel sujet en
préparation d'ailleurs peut-être de
créer des tuyaux dans lesquels on fera
passer de la politique publique avec la
CS 3D demain et avec d'autres choses
c'est c'est un autre sujet mais ça reste
bien un sujet de confor é tant qu'il y a
pas des politiques publiques fortes
derrière les éléments qui soutendent ce
sujet de conformité ou des sanctions au
demeurant fortes on fait pas bouger les
attitudes des entreprises or l'enjeu
principal si on revient à ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est vraiment de
faire bouger les entreprises dans leur
dans leur engagement stratégique de
transition trouver des modèles plus
durables plus résilients moins risqués
parce qu'aujourd'hui on travaille sur la
base de comptabilité et c'est d'ailleurs
vrai à l'échelle la la comptabilité des
pays si je peux me permettre juste ça en
passant sur une vision extrêmement court
terme et ce que nous apportons en
matérialité financière ce que ajoute
ensuite euh les travaux de la CSRD sur
la matérialité d'impact c'est
l'ouverture des horizons dans le temps
et dans et dans l'espace donc ce risque
là moi je le ressens tous les jours
partout en en Europe euh et pourquoi ça
n'est pas transformant simplement parce
que la façon dont sont organisés
aujourd'hui les en entreprise euh ne
permet pas ça c'est-à-dire que si on en
reste à de la conformité ce sera traité
par des organisations et des équipes
dans les dans les staffs des grandes
entreprises en particulier qui sont
totalement déconnectés de la prise de
décision stratégique mais totalement
totalement on sort d'une situation dans
laquelle on est encore d'ailleurs
largement dans une situation dans
laquelle euh les les schémas
organisationnels dans les entreprises en
matière de durabilité reste encore très
séparé des schémas des organisations euh
qui qui budgettent qui font de la
stratégie
euh souvent la durabilité est encore
dans les affaires publiques donc on
parle de conformité est encore euh dans
les organisations de communication on
parle de marketing et on parle de
greenwing euh euh c'est même parfois
dans les directions marketing euh et
parfois c'est directement rattaché au
Président ou à la présidente à la
direction générale mais détaché et pas à
l'intérieur du comité
exécutif les choses évoluent il faut
être clair depuis plusieurs années et
c'est fondamental qu'ell continue à
évoluer mais le risque devant l'ampleur
de la tâche pour la mise en œuvre pour
les entreprises de acsrd c'est que le
premier réflexe c'est de répondre aux
exigences de la CSRD et pour y répondre
de façon sont rapides et pas trop cher
c'est de rester dans la
conformité donc ce qu'il faut arriver à
faire c'est accompagner et je pense que
l'échelle de chacun des pays européens
est importante et pardonnez-moi là je
j'enlève ma casquette issb je reviens
voilà tout simplement
et en tant que chef d'entreprise
français voilà et de nouveau européen
convaincu à l'intérieur de chacun des
pays c'est là que ça que va se jouer
l'en jeu parce qu'aucun des pays n'a la
même culture aucun des pays n européens
n'a la même organisation de gouvernance
des entreprises entre l'Allemagne et la
cogestion et les système français et CEA
on est dans des schémas qui sont
différents donc c'est vraiment au niveau
je
pense souverain de de chacun des pays
que doit se
jouer l'accompagnement stratégique
l'accompagnement de création d'un
écosystème qui va
permettre de
sortir les dispositifs de de durabilité
de de là où ils sont aujourd'hui et de
les intégrer pleinement dans les
processus de décision budgétaire
stratégique évaluation des risques de
gouvernance des
entreprises ça veut dire sans doute que
au-delà même des entreprises il y a pour
moi un travail à faire et et pardon je
le dis comme ça mais je pense qu'il un
travail à faire avec les organisations
professionnelles bien évidemment
patronal mais pas que euh
avec l'AMF sans doute
euh avec les professions d'audit qui
vont être qui ont beaucoup d'enjeux à la
fois économique mais aussi
d'apprentissage de leur point de vue
dans dans l'accompagnement de l'audit et
de la vérification que ce soit de
l'audit financier ou ou pas de mon point
de vue d'ailleurs si je peux me
permettre de le dire ici je pense que
l'importance de la matériel économique
est tellement fondamentale comme l'a
rappelé euh thier
phipona que il me semble capital que au
moins un des auditeurs pour les grandes
entreprises des sujets de durabilité
soit un des auditeurs qui signe les
comptes également qui certifie les
comptes parce que la
connexion avec les les risques les
provisions
l'analyse des bilans et cetera et les
hypothèse qui va être retenue dans les
scénarios qui seront dessinés la
connexion avec les états fin finci est
fondamental si on veut ultimement que
les conversations s'établissent avec des
investisseurs et que les entreprises
dérivent de leur investissement dans ce
qu'est le reporting de la CSRD un retour
qui consistera à peut-être créer un
avantage sur leur coût du capital parce
qu'elles obtiendront de leurs
investisseurs de leurs banquiers je l'ai
fait moi en 2017 donc je vous assure que
si on le fait au niveau systémique ça
peut marcher euh on l'a fait sur un un
prês de 3 milliards d'euros chez Danon
dans lequel il était directement vissé
sur ses conditions financières à deux
indicateurs de durabilité donc il y a ça
marche mais il faut accompagner ça pour
que les entreprises le prennent vraiment
comme un outil stratégique au service de
la transition dont les politique publi
en Europe et en France en particulier on
on ont besoin voilà peut-être je
m'arrête là et puis à votre disposition
bien sûr pour questions merci merci euh
monsieur le Président je vais euh je
vous remercie tous les trois de vos
propos liminires je vais laisser la
parole à nos deux rapporteurs et puis
nos collègues pourront si le temps nous
le permet poser d'autres questions euh
mais je laisse déjà la parole donc à
anne-esophie Romani puis Marion Canales
je vais commencer s'il vous s'il vous
plaît merci euh alors la première
question he qui s'adresse à à vous trois
messieurs et on vous remercie de votre
votre présence au regard des diverg
fondamental qu'on a pu observer entre
l'Europe et les États-Unis sur la la RSE
notamment est-ce qu'il y a un accord
entre ISB et effrag est-il envisageable
si oui à quell conditions autre sujet
qui euh sur lequel nous souhaiterions
vous ins vous vous interpeller c'est euh
la cotation climat préparée par la
Banque de France euh euh qui pour nous
euh pourrait euh s'apparenter et
j'attends votre retour un reporting
extra financier suppémentaire euh
comment est-ce que ça ça pourrait
s'articuler ce qui emmène à une autre
question c'est les euh les risques de
surtransposition en tout cas ces enjeux
de surtransposition euh quel est votre
retour et puis enfin plus largement
est-ce que les entreprises européennes
ne risquentent pas à terme d'être les
plus vertueuses certes mais euh les
moins compétitives en tout cas avoir des
standards tellement exigeants que euh
dans le grand
concert internationale elle serait non
pas ralentie mais en tout cas euh un peu
pénalisé c'est voilà sont les les
questions un peu plus
généralistes au contraire j'aime
beaucoup bon tant mieux parce que c'est
pas fini
ouiou euh pour ma part j'aurais
également quelques questions à vous
poser puisque nous parlons depuis le
début de nos auditions de
1178 indicateurs à traiter par les
fragues et nous avons été interpellés
euh récemment par middl next PME qui
nous parle de 2217 points de vigilance
euh ma première question c'est comment
expliquez-vous qu'on puisse parler parce
qu'on passe quand même du simple au
double donc quel est le nombre de de
points à traiter s'il vous plaît et ne
vous semble-t-il pas que le nombre de
points serait un peu
excessif pour les PME ça c'est ma ma
première question euh j'ai ensuite euh
une autre question pour les PME puisque
la CPME estime que les normes proposées
le 29 novembre sont encore trop lourdes
même s'il y a eu effectivement un
allègement euh et et notamment pour ce
qui concerne le scope 3 du BGS eu et je
voulais savoir si vous aviez procédé à
des tests opérationnels avec des vrais
PME parce que l'impact est quand même
semble en tout cas très important et
puis attirer aussi votre attention euh
sur la la chaîne de valeur de
l'entreprise parce que finalement toutes
les entreprises jacerai principalement
sur les PME euh les PME ne sont pas
toutes éligibles à la CSRD et puis
certaines d'entre elles vont le faire
sous forme de volontariat mais dans la
chaîne de valeur euh de de l'entreprise
dans la chaîne d'approvisionnement
jusqu'au maillon final quand une
entreprise va demander euh une une
entreprise qui devra faire sa CSRD devra
demander au Maillon
final de de de s'expliquer elle aussi
sur son
implication et et et ses orientations
par rapport à cette
responsabilité environnementale et cette
matérialité d'impact comment comment on
va faire par moi c'est c'est une vraie
question là du coup qui me préoccupe euh
voilà cette cette chaîne de valeur et
enfin dernière question
avez-vous mesuré l'impact on entendait
tout à l'heure monsieur Faber parler de
de de l'impact financier sur les
entreprises
eu on entend depuis le début de nos
auditions
euh un impact financier pouvant aller
pour certaines entreprises ne serait-ce
que pour l'étude de la double
matérialité de 150000 à 1 million
d'euros pour les plus gros grosses
entreprises cet impact n'est pas
négligeable et et même si la philosophie
est bonne et et je trouve qu'on n' pas
suffisamment parlé de du côté
introspectif que les entreprises doivent
avoir aujourd'hui il faut effectivement
que ce rapport serve à quelque chose
parce que c'est pour entasser une
paperas supplémentaire je pense que on
va finir par s'y perdre et que on va on
va
décrocher les les entreprises qui auront
envie de investir sur le sujet donc si
c'est simplement pour faire un enè
rapport qui celui-ci sera extra
fininancier certes mais
voilà comment est-ce que on peut avoir
cette philosophie comment on
peut engager les PME à avoir cette
réflexion parce que c'est encore mal
connu le la double matérialité et
l'extrafinancier n'est pas une une des
préoccupations premières des PME
aujourd'hui de certaines en tout cas
donc voilà comment accompagner ces
entreprises et et comment être sûr que
les PME ne diront qu'une fois c'est avec
le dites-le nous une fois pour ne pas
engorger et engluer les PME qui je le
rappelle quand même au passage ont été
créés à la base pour faire de la
valeur même si elles doivent mesurer
leur impact mais leur leur but premier
et aussi de de de produire du résultat
et du chiffre
voilà merci mesdames les rapporteurs je
regarde la la la montre il nous reste on
va dire un quart d'heure euh ce qui vous
ferait dans l'ordre de de vos
interventions chacun 5 minutes euh si
vous pouvez chacun en en à peine 5
minutes condenser vos réponses sur des
questions qui ont été plutôt assez
complètes et larges
merci je commence
oui alors très rapidement euh d'une part
je ne je je ferais attention à à à ne
pas
assimiler les la position
nord-américaine et l'issb je pense
qu'man Fabert aura l'occasion de le
dire donc sur le fond oui je suis très
optimiste sur l'existence de ce que nous
appelons dans notre jargon
l'interopérabilité c'est-à-dire que la
CSRD nous a conduit à élaborer des
standards que la Commission a adopté par
acte
délégué ma vision aujourd'hui c'est que
nous sommes interopérables de en quasi
en quasi totalité c'est-à-dire que le
rapporteur celui qui fait son rapport
ESRS répond aux exigences de de de
l'issb donc je je n'ai pas d'inquiétude
là-dessus je pense qu'on est pas en en
mode complexification on est en mode
simplification et en mode consolidation
des efforts sur la cotation climat que
vous avez évoqué de la Banque de France
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire au
gouverneur je souhaite vivement que si
euh effectivement dans le cadre de FIBEN
quelque chose est fait
par la Banque de France elles prennent
pour base ce que nous demandons des
PME au niveau européen parce que je
pense que il faut éviter la
fragmentation la surtransposition en
France de ce que j'ai vu de la
transposition du 7 décembre je ne vois
pas une
surtransposition il y avait deux ou
trois points qui étaient très
spécifiques à la France ù qui venaient
d'être adopté qui sont ajoutés au
dispositifs de RIP de
d'indicateurs mais ce n'est pas massif à
mon sens précqu alors je suis pas je
suis pas un expert de B écoutez j'en ai
un j'en ai un notamment sur la relation
je crois pardon monsieur Faber
excusez-moi j'avais pas mon micro je
demandais à Monsieur de Cambour s'il
pouvait nous préciser ces deux trois
points de quelle nature était-elle sur
la transposition française alors je je
je j'en ai un en tête pardon parce que
je suis pas un expert de la
transposition française stade puisquelle
est toute récente mais c'est la relation
entre l'entreprise et euh et la défense
donc je qui avait été adop une
disposition qui a été adoptée récemment
par le Parlement et que la
chancellerie et et et le trésor et et
ministère des Finances on ont souhaitait
conserver parce que c'était une
disposition récente je crois qu'il y en
a très peu très vraiment très très peu
euh alors c'est très important toutes
les questions qui tournent autour de du
risque de compétitivité et du risque de
je voudrais dire
d'emblé que
euh je partage le sentiment qui a été
exprimé par par
Emmanuel des des risques de faire un
exercice de
conformité par rapport à au fondamental
qui est de faire un exercice de gestion
de
management c'est on n'est pas là pour
faire du papier hein pas du tout on est
là pour introduire la perspective de
durabilité dans toutes ces dimensions
dans les évolution et la et la et la
stratégie de
l'entreprise je suis un peu moins
pessimiste que que ce qui a été exprimé
par Emmanuel on aura l'occasion d'en
parler on en parle souvent je je trouve
aujourd'hui qu'il y a une véritable
prise de conscience dans le monde des
des des entreprises en Europe alors plus
des grandes aujourd'hui parce que c'est
imminent c'est imminent pour eux euh
mais je je suis pas je suis pas inquiet
j'ai vécu un un épisode vu mon grand âge
similaire au début des années 2000
lorsqu'il s'est agit de passer aux
normes IFRS financière qui a été un un
un un épisode massif ça s'est bien passé
ça s'est bien passé même si tout le
monde
rallait je vous ça a été c'est mais ça
se gère comme un projet et par ailleurs
ça a changé la manière dont les gens ont
réfléchi avant avant si vous voulez on
traduisait les comptes allemands norme
française on se disait ce que ça veut
dire la même chose les aujourd'hui le
langage commun est fondamental j'ajoute
que en fait on parle de coût mais il y a
un coût qu'on ignore on a fait une
analyse de coût bénéfice à frag ça ça
c'est ça fait partie de notre du
process aujourd'hui les entreprises sont
soumises à une rafale et qui devient
tornade de questionnaires
ell viennent des NGOs elles viennent des
investisseurs elles viennent de toutes
parts et si on ne crée pas la plateforme
le but de la normalisation c'est de
créer une plateforme reconnue par tout
le monde et ça donc ça diminue le risque
d'avoir des questionnaires qui partent
dans tous les
aszimutes oui mais ça nécessite aussi
que chaque partie prenante s'investisse
pour alors alors c'est ce pourquoi euh
donc les critiques relatives à la à la
PME bon tout
d'abord le les PME il n'y a que les PME
côté d'O d'où la préoccupation de BINOL
next qui se trouve obligatoirement dans
le champ nous sommes en train de
finaliser hier et nous avons pas pu
terminer donc n avons une réunion demain
soir pour terminer l'exposé sondage
relatif à au au PME côté ce que je peux
dire c'est que le volume est le volume
que vous avez évoqué qui mériterait
beaucoup de discussion parce que parce
que il faut savoir comment en compte
hein oui oui mais non d'accord mais il
faut savoir comment on compte je si vous
voulez là ça ça demanderait presque une
séance mais je suis à la disposition
pour expliquer et il y a un très bon
document qui a été produit qui qui
s'appelle la liste des points
d'information qui est disponible qui a
été approuvé le mois dernier et qui
permet de relativiser les choses parce
que tout cela est soumis à matérialité
mais pour les PME côté on réduit cela
par rapport à ce compte que vous évoquez
de 40 % déjà et je mets je mets en cause
je mets en cause le 4000 le 2000 c'est
c'est une c'est une manière caricaturale
de compter alors en revanche
oui mais madame vous savez combien a de
point d'information pour l'information
financière
pardon alors dernier point dernier point
pour ce qui concerne les PME non queé
nous sommes dans un régime volontaire
nous l'avons fait parce que nous pensons
que les PME ne doivent pas être exclus
du dispositif elles doivent pouvoir
parler elles doivent d'abord introduire
la la la la durabilité dans leur
raisonnement avec des mesures simple de
elles doivent pouvoir parler à leur
banquers leurs financiers de façon
simple sans que ceci exige de façon
bureaucratique des informations qui
iraient au-delà de ce qui est nécessaire
parce que vous savez la nature cré très
volontiers des arbres compliqués et
troisièmement qu'elle puisse s'inscrire
dans les chaînes de valeur et que donc
notre objectif est une plateforme et
nous veillons comme le lait sur le feu à
l'acceptation par les différentes
parties prenantes c'est les utilisateurs
et les préparateurs de ce que nous
faisons j'ai fait avec le président de
la CPME moi-même le
parcours de qu'est-ce que ça
représenterait pour son entreprise pas
pas rapidement bien sûr tr/4 d'heure un
soir tard mais nous avons regardé les 11
informations qui sont demandées dans le
module de base pour savoir si
c'était nager vers
l'Amérique
les informations qui sont demandées
selon le mode puisque c'est une approche
modulaire qui sont demandées sur ce qui
est politique action et et cible et ce
qui était en en ligne pour satisfaire
les exigences éventuelles des acteurs
financiers ou dans la chaîne de valeur
où là il y a aussi une douzaine
d'informations bon j'ai compris qu'il
n'allait pas se jeter ces bureaux sont
très près de la scène qui laisse se
jeter dans la scène immédiatement mais
je comprends que ce soit un souci et
nous faisons tout je discute cet
après-midi avec la Commission sur la
mise en place d'une cellule PME pour
faciliter la mise en place de logiciel
qui aide de répondre à toutes les
questions préoccupations et faciliter
cette cette entrée dans le jeu pardon
j'aiété un peu long et j'ai pas tout
traité merci soucieux du temps je ne
reprendrai pas les points traités par
Patrick decambourg à l'instant sauf
peut-être une minuscule statistique sur
les PME puisquon parle de PME côté PME
côté c'est
0,004 % des PME européennes ce qu'on est
en train de dire c'est que 4000 par
rapport à 22 millions voilà voilà donc
on est en train de dire que
99,996 % je sais même plus comment on
dit quand on va trois chiffres après les
virgules ne seront pas concerné on n'est
pas en train de dire que c'est pas une
vraie question on n'est pas en train de
dire que c'est pas une vraie question
c'est important d'avoir ce chiffre en
tête aussi toutes les PME ne sont pas
concerné c'est vraiment très très
important je pense en tout cas c'est une
statistique qui qui est un
fait je vais dans les quelques courtes
minutes que j'ai peut-être adresser
cette question qui est juste
fondamentale que vous avez soulevé sur
est-ce que les entreprises européennes
doi être plus vertueuses mais moins
compétitive c'est une question
fondamentale c'est une question complexe
c'est une question qui mène à
l'énorme problème qu' a l'humanité je
fais pas d'enhase c'est pas la France
c'est pas l'Europe c'est l'humanité qui
est un problème d'action collective
voilà comment est-ce qu'on fait
travailler tout le monde sur cette
planète ensemble si vous avez la
solution surtout n'hésitez pas à
m'appeler
euh voilà une fois qu'on a dit ça et là
je vais revenir à ce que je disais tout
à l'heure est-ce qu'on peut être je
d'abord je pense que le mot vertueux
n'est pas le bon c'est pas une question
de vertu c'est une question qui consiste
juste à analyser que quand on n pas
beaucoup de temps donc je vais juste me
référer comme tout à l'heure d'ailleurs
au rapport du
si ce que nous dit le GC qui sont un des
scientifiques de très important à avoir
en tête les rapports du G ont été
filtrés par tous les gouvernants du
monde donc mécaniquement c'est
normal il y a eu un filtre voilà malgré
ça les rapports du je on se dit ou là là
ça va pas être terrible pour l'économie
donc c'est pas une question de vertu
c'est une question bien pragmatique et
bien concrète de si tout cela se produit
demain je vais clairement pas être
compétitif alors ça résout pas notre
problème de compé aujourd'hui ou
compétitif dans dans 10 ans j'ai
tendance à penser que si les entreprises
européennes
s'embarquent vers un chemin
de plus grande prise en compte de la
durabilité je fais exprès d'utiliser une
expression très générale parce qu'on a
pas le temps bah peut-être que dans 10
ans 15 ans 20 ans elle se rend très très
très heureuse d'avoir pris ce chemin je
suis pas en train de dire que il y a pas
des vraies questions à court terme et ça
ça rejoint et on n' pas le temps à ce
que disait Emmanuel Fabert tout à
l'heure sur sur la
conformité on est d'accord la conformité
seule bon voilà après ça on est en train
de parler de standard de reporting
est-ce que une entreprise a le choix de
déterminer comment elle calcule son
profit en comptabilité financière ah ben
non ton profit c'est ça et puis on te
laisse pas le choix d'être créatif sur
la la détermination de ton profit donc
c'est de la conformité simplement ce
qu'on est en train de dire et on l'a dit
tous de nombreuses fois depuis le début
de de de de de de cette audition c'est
que la conformité seule n'est pas
suffisante et c'est ce que je disais au
début de mon introduction tout à l'heure
de mon propos qui est c'est une pièce
d'un puzzle beaucoup plus large voilà
donc dire
ah on fait que de la conformité donc ça
va pas suffire c'est une pièce du puzzle
voilà je pense qu'il faut vraiment le le
réser comme ça pardonnez-moi monsieur
philippeona je vous coupe pas hein non
non non continuez continuez juseque moi
j'ai un train à prendre donc je vais
être obligé de vous laisser je tenais à
vous remercier tous les TR
non mais continuez c'est Michel canev
vice-président de la délégation qui
prend ma ma relève mais merci encore de
votre présence et je vous laisse
continuer merci merci à vous je pense
que je vais je vais m'arrêter là parce
que Patrick de Cambourg a traité
beaucoup de sujets et puis je voulais je
voulais mettre en en exerg cette
opposition vertu compétitivité et
et moi dans mon métier je ne suis pas
partisan c'est pas mon métier à chacun
son
métier on on voit des camps partisans
ceux qui sont pour la compétitivité ceux
qui sont pour la vertu je l'ai dit je
pense pas que c'est une question de
vertu et je pense pas que la
compétitivité puisse exister sans la
durabilité donc je j'ai envie très
modestement dans la fonction qui est la
mienne d'encourager le débat public à
dépasser ce que j'appellerai une fausse
dichotomie je pense que c'est vraiment
important ce qui veut pas dire que il y
a pas des vraies questions hein parce
que si si je suis rentable de main enfin
vous êtes rentable dem main je ne le
suis pas bah les por de force et cetera
nous le savons merci beaucoup Monsieur
Philippe hard effectivement il y a un
certain nombre d'entreprises seulement
de de avec un chiffre d'affaires et un
niveau d'activité important qui seront
concernés mais il faut aussi évaluer
celles qui sert concerné par impact
c'est-à-dire l'ensemble de la
sous-traitance qui pourrait
effectivement
devoir s'y référer également peut-être
que Emmanuel Faber veut bien poursuivre
le les les
réponses merci
ouais je vais aussi euh je pense ne pas
être exhaustif sur ces toutes ces
questions importantes et il y en a sur
lesquelles en particulier je je suis
assez peu euh pertinent j'imagine euh
sur la question euh je vais le dire tout
de suite sur la trans sur transposition
j'ai aucune compétence à la matière euh
et j'ai un peu d'expérience donc je
pense que le pragmatisme serait vraiment
une très très bonne idée mais audelà de
ça je j'imagine que tout le monde en est
convaincu autour de cette table euh 2è
point sur la cotation climat de la
Banque de France euh de nouveau je
prends le sujet à à un niveau plus
global la supervision euh bancaire euh
est en marche sur ces questions et en
particulier dans ces question sur ces
questions climatiques euh pour pas dire
un peu plus loin d'ailleurs sur des
questions de de lien avec la
biodiversité elle est au point que le
comité de bal euh a confirmer
l'utilisation des outils que nous avons
développés les normes climatiques que
nous avons développé pour son travail
futur sur les ratios de solvabilité de
liquidité bancaire en matière de risque
climatique donc ce n'est peut-être pas
la Banque de France pour cette fois-ci
mais c'est le comité de bal qui a donc
une supervision systémique sur ces
questionsl et donc ça veut dire que pour
les compagnies d'assurance pour les
banques pour les gestionnaires d'actifs
il y aura une supervision active et
comme vous le savez par ailleurs à
l'échelon européen dès l'année dernière
la Banque centrale européenne a fait
tourner des scénarios climat pour a
demander à 150 banques européennes de
faire tourner les scénarios climat et
dès le mois d'octobre 2022 elle a tenu à
envoyer un signal de marché euh en
évoquant le fait que pour la poignée de
ces banques qui n'avaient vraiment pas
passé le test correctement entre
guillemets elle appliquait d'ors et déjà
des élément de capital qui tenait compte
du risque qu'elle estimait elle-même en
tant que collatéral garant et
superviseur euh à l'égard de ces banques
donc la question de la compétitivité
climatique des banques au travers du
système de super visision elle est c'est
même plus une question c'est c'est juste
une question de temps ce sera peut-être
long ça sera compliqué et cetera mais ça
arrivera et je vous invite vraiment à ne
pas laisser ça dans un angle mort parce
que comme la finance a évidemment et
comme on disait tout à l'heure un enjeu
absolument majeur de transition si la
supervision bancaire commence à
l'échelle mondiale à établir que selon
le la température des portefeuilles
bancaires on va le dire comme ça ces
banques ont des profils de risque qui
sont différents c'est là bien la
compétitivité bancaire qui se pose et
donc ultimement elles vont être un
acteur d'allocation d'actifs non plus
d'actif côté comme je le mentionné tout
à l'heure de l'obligation côté ou des
actions côté mais de prêt privé
évidemment c'est un énorme facteur de
changement donc on l'aime on l'aime pas
dites-vous que c'est là et donc gardez
bien ça en tête d'une façon ou d'une
autre si si c'est possible je pense sur
la question des entreprise vertueuse pas
vertueuse la compétitivité pour moi
c'est le point fondamental et c'est
évidemment pas là qu'on peut le Tr
traité j'ai commis un petit un petit
livre qui parle d'alpinisme mais qui
parle aussi de compétitivité écologique
et sociale il y a il y a un an et demi
dans lequel je dis non seulement elle
est possible mais elle est nécessaire
elle est urgente donc on va pas le faire
là mais je reprends un certain nom dans
dans ces éléments là j'entends Thierry
filpona reprendre des éléments que que
je pense les gens qui travaillent sur
ces questions connaissent il est évident
qu'aujourd'hui on est sur des mécanismes
de valorisation de la compétitivité à
extrêmement court terme qu'on valorise
au travers des coûts si vous allez sur
le site du ministère des Finances vous
regardez compétitivité l'indicateur de
compétitivité c'est les coûts quand on
dit que dans les coûts on ne compte pas
tout et notamment pas tous les risques
de durabilité donc la résilience de ce
système de coût et de la comptabilité au
même moment où Patrick de Cambourg TH
philippona et moi on vous dit on est en
train d'embarquer à l'échelle
mondiale autre chose que la comptabilité
d'aujourd'hui on lui accolle un système
qui peut transformer l'économie alors
évidemment ça veut dire que quand on va
parler de compétitivité ce sera pas les
mêmes coûts ce sera pas la même ça ne
peut pas être uniquement les coûts tels
qu'on les mesure aujourd'hui puisque il
y a tout un tas de risques qui ne sont
pas pris en compte donc c'est bien une
question de de de transition vers tout
ça et comment est-ce que une allocation
de ces actifs est est possible j'arrête
là mais moi je pense que c'est possible
ça nécessite des choix qui ne sont
d'ailleurs pas seulement des choix
globaux je voudrais dire que je pense
qu'on peut même construire une
compétitivité à l'échelle d'un pays à
l'échelle d'une d'une région comme
l'Europe est en train de le faire à sa
façon autour d'un d'un d'un système à
condition qu'il soit cohérent et je
voudrais insister à condition qu'il soit
très très fortement focalisé vers la
mise en œuvre de laallocation du capital
c'est-à-dire l'information pour les
investisseurs et les banquiers au
travers de ce que les équipes de
management vont vont développer en terme
de de stratégie l'autre aspect
compétitivité c'est notre travail
c'est-à-dire que quand on parle de
compétitivité climat on a des normes
climat qui en substance pas dans leur
ganérité parce qu'à côté de ça l'Europe
a un ensemble de de d'éléments de
reporting climat que nous n'avons pas
parce qu'ils ne sont pas économiquement
pertinents par construction puisque
sinon c'est dans l'interopérabilité que
nous avons ensemble qui sont des
éléments de politique publique de
granularité locale et cetera et cetera
et qui sont assez nombreux mais sur la
substance de la transformation la
capacité de transformation économique on
a vraiment des normes qui sont
extrêmement proches les mêmes niveau
d'exig
dites-vous une chose c'est que le Brésil
a déjà annoncé qu'en
2026 il rendrait obligatoire
l'utilisation de nos normes c'estàdire
que le soja qui est importé du Brésil
vers l'Europe quand on s'inquiète de du
mécanisme
d'ajustement du carbone à la frontière
ce soja sera soumis par les entreprises
au travers des entreprises brésiliennes
à la même mesure de ces émissions de gaz
à effet de serre que ce que l'on demande
en Europe euh le Japon a annoncé nos
normes ou des normes intégrant est
nôutes en 2025 la Turquie l'a annoncé à
la COP 28 en 2024 l'Angleterre est sur
ce chemin donc plus on va établir des
normes de climat aussi exigeante ce qui
est le cas que celle construite par les
frages acté dans la CSRD à l'échelle
international et plus on viendra sur le
climat en tout cas dans un premier temps
s'assurer qu'on a bien un niveau de
compétitivité qui ne se compare pas sur
les éléments de transparence et donc
c'est
vraiment c'est absolument en ça que
notre travail est je pense
complémentaire de celui de juridiction
comme l'Europe mais évidemment d'autres
juridictions parce qu'in finé le besoin
des investisseurs c'est de c'est d'avoir
un langage comptable unique 30 % des
investisseurs du CAC40 sont des
investisseurs américains aujourd'hui on
on l'aime on l'aime pas moi j'ai vécu
avec ça pendant 25 enfin pendant 20 ans
mais donc ça veut dire que ces
investisseurs sont globaux et si on leur
propose un langage global ça veut dire
que des entreprises européennes mieux
préparées peut-être que d'autres sur ces
éléments là pourront de nouveau
bénéficier d'avantage concurrentielle en
capital dernière chose et je serai
vraiment très
bref vous avez évoqué madame romaniie en
particulier la question du coût
évidemment c'est un coût
mais tout toute la question c'est que je
pense que si on en reste à la conformité
c'est un coup et c'est quasiment que un
coup pardonnez-moi pour ce simplisme
mais si on passe à une question
d'investissement et de stratégie et
comme le disait Patrick tout à l'heure
de management décision de management
alors ça n'est pas un coup c'est un
investissement et cet investissement il
faut le faire euh simplement on aura de
retours sur cet investissement que si le
système extrait de ça des informations
qui vont permettre aux entreprises la
prise de décision et ultimement
d'obtenir les capitaux dont elles ont
besoin de ce point de vue-là les PME je
dirais juste une chose nous on a reporté
du périmètre 3 80 % de ce périmètre 3
chez Danon il est dans l'agriculture
parce que c'est une entreprise qui
repose sur l'utilisation des sols on
n'est jamais allé demander une une seule
fois à à l'un des
300000 éleveurs avec lesquels on
travaillait dans le monde de nous
préparer un reporting sur son propre
périmètre 1 2 ou 3 d'émission dans ces
champs on travaille avec des ABAC avec
des facteurs d'émission avec tout un tas
de truc avec la FAO on a développé tous
un système qui permet de repérer en
fonction du type d'agriculture du type
de récolte de la pédoclima du pédoclimat
local et en faisant des audits sur ces
questionsl des systèmes performants en
quelques années qui nous ont permis à 5
6 peut-être 10 % près maximum de mesurer
nos émissions sans jamais aller emmerder
quiconque donc euh je pense que c'est
vraiment très important de de de laisser
les chaînes de valeur s'organiser
elles-même parce que par exemple ce qui
s'est passé c'est que lorsque Lactalis
Nesle ou d'autres allit sur les mêmes
zones de collecte des des elbeurs qui
avaient cette information pour nous
pouvaient donner exactement la même à
leurs autres grands clients donc c'est
c'est il faut réfléchir aussi en terme
de Figuière et c'est pour ça que je me
permettais tout à l'heure dire les
associations professionnelles vont être
des partenaires importants je pense dans
l'écosystème de construction d'un
système dans lequel autant que possible
on laisse faire mécanismes de marché
s'installer et on les corrige là où il
faut par des mécanismes réglementaires
voarte là et bonne chance à T et à tout
cette passionnanteaventure merci puisse
la manière de faire de d'on prospérer
avec anemien sénatrice de odmarne Michel
mass sénateur de hgaron les deux
rapporteurs Anne Sophie romag et Marion
Canales on tient à vous remercier patri
de Cambourg Thierry philippona et
Emmanuel Fabert de votre participation à
cette table ronde très intéressante je
dis à mes collègues que l'on donne
rendez-vous le 17 janvier le mercredi 17
janvier prochain pour une nouvelle
édition de la parole aux entrepreneurs
donc notez cela sur votre agenda et puis
merci de vos contributions donc et je
souhaite à chacun de joyeuses fêtes de
fin d'année merci beaucoup bonne journée
merci beaucoup merci